what is this place  safe house  let's hope  honey  i'm home  hi  company  sorry didn't call ahead  this is an agent of some kind  gentlemen  this is laura  i know all your names  oh incoming  i hi sweetheart hey buddy how you guys  doing  dessert look at your face smaller agents  oh my goodness did you bring any nuts  why don't you hug her and find out  sorry for barging in on you yeah we  would have called ahead but we were busy  having no idea that you existed yeah  well fury helped me set this up when i  joined  kept it off shields finals like to keep  it that way  i figure it's a good place to lay low  honey  i missed you  that's a little natasha  nathaniel  trader  thor  i saw something in that dream i need  answers  i won't find him here  we can go home  you